we work for the company we love the
company the the company what's follow
the ice cream truck we love the compy
the we going
right Mark seems to be sinking into
something oh he found quick and is dead
[__]
out so I found a turret
I love the
company the company but let me know if
there's anything ooh what is this do you
hear that
[Music]
BX uh that's Mark's mating call did we
do it we did it day oh oh not that oh no
sorry that's company property now no I I
don't know don't tell you're walking I'm
not I'm not I'm not
mark
they may not like you ringing their Bell
constantly me I could I could tell when
Wade's doing a thing that's like you
guys should not do this dumb
[Music]
thing okay well that
I is that what you wanted waade is that
what you wanted to happen that is what I
didn't want that's why the company likes
why didn't you say it in a way that's
like oh you shouldn't do
this yeah you shouldn't is that is that
what is it mine now do I inherit it I
mean I guess Bob's part of the company
now sold no you fool Hey listen that's
Bob's walkie it goes to where he goes
that's fair is he going to take it that
one's for you Bob where'd it go I looked
away what happened it took it oh oh hey
wait a minute wait you you bought us bad
walk jeez that thing was worthless how
where's Bob uh we have to go back into
space to find him D I think okay space
space start sh go space go to we just
we're launching start
ship go up big how in the world we
actually met the first quarter I don't
know I want
space Bob
alive hey
hey that last command's pretty powerful
what's up hey don't worry I
Revenge I got that walk you sent for me
oh cool good great can you show us uh
well uh I donated it to the company cuz
I love it that's fair you know what
that's fair I love the company can I say
I love the company the
company we love the company where are we
going yeah what do one of you guys to
pick a moon don't me to you guys pick I
don't have to pick
moons yeah we got big smart guy here
with his brain oh I I got the report
Wade uh you're uh uh
dumb oh wait no and stupid oh
ugly oh and uh bald it's in the report
man I I don't know what to tell you I
don't know what to tell you
it's
no
yeah it's actually
um the oh man I'm so
sorry you're ugly does there's no way
does it say that oh sorry it's a
privileged company information you can't
look at the
reports when I work for the company yeah
well I'm L I'm going to put the boat
down boys all right he wait how did you
buy um how did you buy walkies just
curious store I just bought some more
but all you do is you type store on
there and then you type walkietalkie
then how many you want or you just typ
walkies or walkie I already bought I
already bought three walkies
and does hazard level be that is that
like a good rating like yippee well be
careful B is okay it's a little bit
above average
danger uh o all right I guess I'm going
on an adventure Mark are you staying on
the boat do you no I'm buying some Stu
I'll be I'll be right there hold on what
do you what do you with what with what
money sir my money I already stuff so I
don't know what you're
buying wa the ice cream machine oh I
could have bought a oh I could have
bought a pro flashlight it was on
sale oh I bought
a all right hey whoa hey whoa hey hey
hey hey
hey Mark come here Mark come here come
over here look oh this what you're
looking for okay we're good there's also
a shovel here on the ground that oh
actually that's mine Mark do you need a
flashlight huh I got one I got two
flashlights so I I feel like hey guys
what's up did you buy some stuff wait do
you need a flashlight I know I I bought
three flashlights three walkies I think
I bought a couple shovels don't worry
we'll just shine light off his head and
it'll illuminate the
whole come on man the didn't say
that
guy's a
jerk aha anyway peace and quiet why does
it look like eyeballs it's a little
concerning that's dark and
ominous
H that's also dark and
ominous hm
well this a terrible without anyone here
okay
oh hi hi you didn't turn your walkie
on I don't have one we
bought anyway I got some says he doesn't
have a walk
yeah whatever that's why I don't listen
to you he's here hey
Mark
Mark Mark
Mark I got there's a walkie here for you
buddy oh cool yeah I was wondering about
that ooh it's uh sitting on the shelf
there a sick flashlight is this a pro
flashlight yeah the yellow ones are pro
pro ones oh the yellows are pro
ah uh yeah walkie um okay so where's
Wade he's in the he's still in the
facility oh okay all right well you want
to go in or uh you want to oh wait's
actually on the way back um Mark take
MEK take me huh take you
show me show me the way show me the way
okay say this way all right take me Mark
take me oh well okay wait mar mar bring
me into the facility I saw all the way
back yeah hi yeah
hi uh I I thought I remember the
facility entrance being
here
[Applause]
um uh Mark um Mark about some
quick
again I love the company the company hey
oh the
company the entrance is straight ahead
when you leave the ship ah okay I cannot
believe you found quick standand again
he literally full speed right to the
dead center of the quick sand and died
wait what is that what is that do you
see
that what there was something like
running around over
here oh no I didn't okay maybe I'm just
no no no no
no um do we leave and go get mark
back uh was um after six yeah let's go
wait Mark's already trying to leave
without us a vote has been cast
that's son of a [__]
to I feel pretty good about that hey our
quick boy hey what's up man man I had
the craziest dream yeah what happened
yeah I uh I dreamed that I fell into a a
lake of Despair and held out my hand for
my friend and went save me save me and I
saw him standing there watching me slip
under the darkness that's crazy that's
funny cuz I had a dream that I laughed
hysterically yeah into bit of Despair
right the laughing I had dream that I
stood here watching two dots stand side
by side as one got darker and
disappeared man we had I want to go
inside the next one I want to go inside
the next all right a location I didn't
mean to volunteer to be ship guy again
Mark you pick I picked the last one you
picked all right you got it okay here we
go I need to buy another
walkie I don't know if we can afford it
but youy oh we cannot we cannot afford
that wow yeah the bottom three are
expensive why do they cost money are we
buying the planet because they have the
best stuff you make the most there so
you get charged to go oh interesting
H let's do this let's
do you right Mark here you go markk have
mywa I'm going to buy another one a
thanks man all right hey this looks
familiar oh yeah hey no yeah I know this
one hold on I need to charge my
flashlight sand quick sand yeah what's
up what about it quick
quicksand yeah quicksand uh-huh yeah 10
objects inside worth
$691 whoa each so you're saying there's
a chance total total not e total holy
[__] each no I think he's the total I'm
fairly
certain it's here I think the ice cream
truck is for Wade yeah I know all right
I got my I got my walkie on all right we
we're here we're about to go
the okay we're inside ooh it's
dark fire exit's right there already
that's yeah how do you know that fire
exit oh Bob uh go back way you came in
right at the end of this hallway yeah
and then straight at the end of this and
keep going keep going straight keep
going straight oh yeah I see it too
huh
oh there's an enemy coming up toward you
what what do you mean what do you mean
what do you mean what do you mean um it
turned
around what do you mean it turned
around
stiny oh oh oh oh oh oh
oh arms crawling yeah there's a
guy
Mark hi oh you're fine oh yeah I don't
feel
good uh wait what does it mean if I'm
all red in the in the in the my body it
means you got hit you're almost
dead so I should go back in in or no on
that what do we think well we're going
to we're going to teach that thing a
lesson for hurting you what wait what we
what do you mean teach the lesson we oh
we're going to teach the lesson Mark
where you at we're going to avenge B
what's the lesson plan what do you mean
avenge Bob he's he's right here lesson
one grab a
shovel all I'm going to go back to the
ship l no you know what you know what I
want to I want to see I want to see you
guys get my Vengeance lesson three
lesson three go in oh okay all right um
well we don't have
okay take this you bastard there's two
of
them no all right okay
so
that oh I about what happened and not at
all I really want to try and get Wade's
body and also we should try and Salvage
is like Walky and stuff but um well okay
about that see oh uh-huh this isn't um
you uh but hey hold on a second I've got
an idea Mark I well would if you
okay
oh my God oh my
God
bed that's that's a lot of blood on the
ground going to take this stuff and go
back to the ship yeah uh it um Mark
avenge us oh boy okay all right well
just um that was a lot of blood I'm fine
I'm fine don't worry about
me what you got to get W's body and his
stuff Mark I believe in
you
okay I I'll watch you on the on the
monitors and I know you can do it bud so
you just let me know when it's
clear I um can't see inside unless
you're
inside uh oh wait actually I can monitor
Wade's body um they're like patrolling
they're like patrolling the area wait
wait a minute no that's not very safe um
do you think these things can open
doors uh probably not when you go in
there's a door that closes the hallway
to your right when I go in you're
presuming a lot yeah yeah when you go in
there's a door the the door to your
right is closable if they're both on the
other side of that door and you close it
it probably will be stuck behind that
all right okay yeah just tell me when to
the right right now is the time no no no
oh that one can teleport I don't like
that that's not good for your chances
that's not good uh now is your chance go
okay here I go I'm going I'm going I'm
[Music]
going man that thing was fast oh by the
way you don't have to tell Bob this but
they can open doors ah well yeah we'll
keep that between us
uh just charge on my walk I just love
that I charged in there all confident
and died instantly yeah those uh how how
many hits does it take to kill that
thing I think three ah I should have hit
it one more time I was yeah I think it
was like one hit away
oh that thing is fast we almost got him
we had him on the Rope so [__]
fast Jesus it was on the other end of
the of that long hallway from you like
all the way and then as soon as you
stepped inside it like teleported right
to you it didn't teleport my bro it ran
oh well it it ran so fast the scanners
could barely keep up with it yeah same
same with my eyes just a kind of just a
blur I'm going to just if anyone wants
it I'll go ahead and just put that
walkie down there and that yeah we have
one shovel one light one walkie right
now and it's not the best combo let me
just check out the store real quick here
we have no money we have 0 all right
okay we don't need tech we don't need
this nonsense we just go in there chest
out baby all right look out for
[Music]
quicksand
hello
hello oh hey oh there you are what uh
what was the deal want to make sure Bob
knew how to get back oh okay hi hi took
a I thought I was scared for a second I
thought I was
alone
well ah and everything's fine all right
whoa it's dark I'll go this way where
there's light I miss having light hello
darkness my old friend
heit it's over here a good keep up the
good
work nice dead end beautiful don't
worry oh into the
darkness I found this empty hey I hear a
turret
oh to switch did that well yeah why that
why that that
happened I I flipped the switch why why
where are you hello hi what's up hey
what go
out
um can you can you turn it back on oh
okay good oh there we go hey all right
well I'm just going to not mess with
that anymore that's fine yeah that'd be
ideal this hey Bob remember that turn
that shot you to death sure sure yeah I
I heard one of those then the lights
went out so I didn't look for it very
long it probably turned off the power to
it so that was probably a good
thing uh yeah probably probably I feel
like we're all going the same way here
yeah oh yeah I'll go yeah Bob that's
good made it okay here we go whoa what
did I I just got a uh I just saw a ping
of okay what
oh God what ises that
sound he had something on his head he
fell to his death oh no well he was
probably going to die anyway he had
something hey oh hey
Bob I was
wrong it's land
mines oh yeah no I found that by walking
within inches of it but somehow not
setting it
off
okay that's a dead end well I have an
engine so that's that's pretty good
right yeah those are real good for
jumping across long distances while
holding okay good cool well that's
probably what I'm going to have to do so
that's convenient oh hey engine Bros oh
yeah Mark with coach
at if had already K himself all cool
like cookie
pan nice
nice I feel like this is not a stop sign
oh you can shovel it's a weapon all
right all right now we're getting
somewhere I I'm having a thought right
now that I'm trying really hard not to
say out loud oh what's that I'm trying
not to say it out loud but I okay I'll
I'll manifest
the Universe um man it's weird that
we're not encountering any creatures or
anything this
weird and then it's we're continuing to
not encounter any creatures just how
fortuitous is that dead end oh okay
that's kind of where I thought we were
supposed to go me too it's just further
down this way oh yeah no no no no come
here I I remember this come here come
here come here we love the company uh
it's over this way okay I got to drop
this off my I can't Car drop it outside
yeah your voice cut off in a perfect
Echo is beautiful oh right as I was
leaving you were just
like I just did it to you yeah it's
already late oh my God we're have to
shuffle items to get back with all of
them if once you're exiting here it's
like straight ahead to the right yeah
over here here yeah it's like straight
ahead over that
mountain oh for God's sakes I think we
just go to the right here yeah oh
okay yeah I see the ship oh
growling wait the
[__] wait there's a dinosaur dinosaur
there's a your G
sh oh no oh no
oh
oh yeah hey what's up
man
so it's not attacking Wade and he's
being conspicuously quiet interesting
interesting interesting yeah that's
that's funny how that works uh maybe we
should vote to let the ship leave early
how do we do
that that would be a dick move oh I see
I see I see oh oh oh man no I I vote I
vote that we move I I vote to leave I
vote to yeah let's move this along let's
move this along he better hurry up I
think he's trying to avoid attracting
the attention of the dino doggy thing
all right hope he doesn't hit
quicksand oh
uhoh might have an issue
here I'm sure he's got time right is he
hearing the dinosaur is that what he's
maybe Zach didn't real par okay he did
it look at that look at all the money we
get guy
wow Mone for us got to be good enough oh
that's so much money left out the table
though that's unfortunate ah no better
than nothing right I mean yeah well Bob
you asked for creatures I guess I should
have manifested that but you really
manifested it oh hey what's up hey man
who yeah I don't seem to be in ACR any
experience it seems to just be like a
little bit you got to got to live for
that I think if you die you lose all
your yeah well that I think that is the
problem all right well I'm going to turn
in some of this stuff yep yep oh one
actually that can't hold anymore
oh well that's a little Annoying don't
you think oh is
[Music]
it
yippe safe
I I feel safe I feel like it's my fault
Bob that you w that animal into
existence yes we agree no yeah it's
definitely your
fault are we going to make it do we have
enough
money
cell cell oh oh
[Music]
back
do you think it's the
horn I don't know I'm curious what
exactly the horn does though well hey
that's pretty good well we might need to
sell the
Horn uh yeah quota is 23 252 we made 232
we need 20 more or something will happen
probably what happens that what what
happens
move huh
that horn is making them very angry that
didn't make any
sense I don't see what you're so worried
about yeah I don't see what you're so
worried
about
whoa
[Music]
W oh whoa that's an expensive clown can
I just keep going
what the
freak why does it keep
going
what okay oh is this wait
oh oh
oh
oh oh s
what
oh
hey did you find Mar no and I didn't
find the end I just decided to turn
around cuz I got scared I think he's
dead okay well I guess we should leave
for the company the I found Where the
Sidewalk Ends
comp unfortunately I do have to go okay
how much money did we make we have
yeah what can we buy our new quota is
358 uh what are you wanting to buy cuz
we might want some of that money for you
know useful
equipment oh
boy why are we going I thought Bob had
to yeah I to leave and I'm the host so
this is all about to end okay all right
you don't want to see the present file
will not save your ship must be in or oh
oops Yeah is that an explosion was is
that can we grab the present and then go
to orbit
[Music]
wow
oh yeah we got it what' you what' you
buy you ready you ready you
ready oh hell
yeah
all right absolutely worth it oh let's
get the hell out of here baby let's get
the hell out of
here for the company I actually lived go
all over the place for
the for theany we push real hard for the
company company came real hard for
company sorry I got really into
[Music]
that
everybody